[Musique]
ce côté là ça va mais de l'autre côté
notre côté on va avoir des trous
[Musique]
mais on prend toutes les mesures
anatomique longueur des nageoires
longueur la longueur totale ont fait des
prélèvements sur des animaux
relativement frais le large musclée dans
en général on prend les dents pour avoir
l'âge de du dauphin
[Musique]
le but de cette campagne c'est d'exposer
sa à travers les médias pour que les
gens et notamment les consommateurs se
rendent compte de ce qui se passe et
qu'ils se rendent compte que quand ils
achètent certains poissons et bien il ya
certains ça ça implique des conséquences
et les conséquences dans ce cas là ce
sont ses dauphins qui sont pris dans les
filets donc des centaines voire même des
milliers chaque année on essaye de faire
pression sur les sur les gouvernements
pour que pour que ce genre de pratique
cesse et soit plus réglementé parce que
parce qu'on se rend compte que c'est pas
durable
[Musique]
je vois et c'est juste derrière
électoral devant la dorsale qui pourra
pas qualifié le type d'engins de pêche
qui était responsable de leur mort mais
malheureusement oui
l'essentiel des individus qu'on retrouve
actuellement et qu'on examine
actuellement sur l'arc atlantique sont
liés de la capture accidentelle
là on voit que c'est un animal de très
bonne condition physique c'est à dire
que là il ya des muscles très galbées il
n'est pas maigre du tout et donc rien de
majeur en apparence externe de cause de
mortalité naturelle on va dire et puis
tout de suite qu'on voit c'est
rapidement sont des marquages de la peau
avec dessous des hématomes on voit ici
des coupures très très fine
on voit de sa forme d encerclement en
fait l'animal est émaillée et enfin dans
les derniers éléments on voit ces partis
bleus
rose et rouge qui constituent des
hématomes généralisée et ça c'est
caractéristique d'une mort en profondeur
par asphyxie ces animaux se noient pas
d'humeur du fait de ne pas pouvoir
remonter à la surface ce qui nous
inquiète c'est qu'en fait ce sont des
animaux qui ont un taux de croissance
très faible
ils grandissent
pas très vite leur population met du
temps à se renouveler et donc le jour on
va réellement observées un déclin dans
la population
il sera trop tard il ya déjà des
exemples en france heureusement peu en
europe mais il ya d'autres exemples dans
le monde le marsouin en californie il
est en train de disparaître espèce
éteinte raison la pêche
on a mis trop de temps à comprendre le
problème contre autant à trouver des
mesures la jcct ne contribue qu'à une
part qu'une part très faible de ceux de
ces captures accidentelles quoi la
grande part ça peut être d'autre
d'autres activités de pêche d'autres
d'autres métiers d'autres d'autres
nations ça peut être aussi des
phénomènes naturels ça peut être aussi
des ddd tempête qui finalement révèle le
plus ce phénomène là que dans les années
passées
le klinger se met en route au contact de
l'autre dès qu'ils déclenchent à lui
rentrer dans l'eau le pilleur se met en
route et commence à émettre donc des
gens de maison d'à côté acoustique qui
vont du coup éloigner le dauphin de de
l'engin de pêche
thimoté
[Musique]
il
un bon coup
vous
[Musique]
on
bonjour
[Musique]
doux